hey I you last week told me that some
open-mike her stole your joke and that
Ali Wong reported it to you oh yeah
what joke I said that I'm dating my joke
as a vegan I love jungle Asians you know
they're the best oh that's your turn
yeah no that's not the joke the joke
goes there amazing they can peel mangoes
with their feet so funny because I hear
those things but me you know Barton Joe
yeah yeah we do
and so Ali Wong texted me and she goes
someone stole judge oak and I'm gonna
gonna call you and some guy from I
didn't say his name but from Sacramento
or whatever calls me because hey I did
it your joke on my album and I'm sorry
whatever album yeah oh [ __ ]
and I go because he had opened for me
yeah but what I'm saying though is this
is it that I'm not like some other
comedy police where I go crazy because I
know that we absorb them a lot of times
stealing is absorption it's not it's not
intentional sometimes it's like yeah you
hear something fusion it's in your
subconscious a year later
yeah you think of it you think it's your
own idea and then you write it down yeah
and then that's to a certain extent I
completely agree but when it's like bit
for bit yeah performance for emotion
yeah that's like some different [ __ ] you
know I mean we're like you did exactly
the way yeah
what am I gonna do he put on his album
I'm gonna [ __ ] yell at him I know
it's cool dude don't worry about it yeah
but that's even amazing of Ali Wong to
how honorable a night Exeter you're
honorable
let me see something about Ali Wong
she's [ __ ] honorable and I'm gonna say
this she won't do the podcast because
she just doesn't do podcasts but if she
did podcast she'd be on the show
but she's you know an honorable lady and
a person she is a lot of the kooky
Asians are really the kooky groups who
are honorable I honestly guy who stole
your [ __ ] was he no oh what was an Asian
no he's talking about jungle Asia
jungle a dog oh [ __ ] I want to say about
you know the Hispanic comedy scene in
the 90s was a war there was just people
not getting along with each other and
there wasn't really an Asian scene so no
camaraderie so you know there was a lot
of like a Willie Barcena is gonna show
up to the comedy store with a bat to
beat in johnny-san no Jeff Garcia Jeff
Garcia showed up to the comedy store
with a knife to stab Johnny Sanchez yeah
so then Jeff Garcia Johnny didn't show
up because he knew that Jeff was at was
there with a knife
these are comedians so that Jeff Garcia
went up on stage and then try to stab at
audience member and they got banned from
the car yeah so there's a being wasn't
satisfied he I just had to do somebody's
head II can't get it out and then like
when George Lopez almost strangled
Carlos Mencia to death in the lobby of
the Laugh Factory yeah yeah so yeah a
lot of that going on
[Music]